we want to look at this pulley system we
want to find out what this force here is
for example with which this block is
being poked now we have two massless
polizia and two moving parts and one key
component of this problem is to derive
the acceleration constraint how we're
going to do that well we have to look at
this string here first of all it's a
fixed string length and that will help
us ultimately this is just a distance
that connects all of these objects and
if we eventually differentiate that
twice we get to an acceleration so the
first thing we're going to do is to
derive the to figure out what the string
length is and we then derive the
acceleration condition let's begin by
first identifying the fixed length in
this problem so we have a little
distance here we call it SB and we have
a distance here that's fixed as a and we
furthermore know that this block here is
fixed to the ground and we can choose a
coordinate system origin let's say we do
that here we know that we have the
distance D here - to this little block
the moving parts block 1 and block 2 so
we have to assign position functions and
actually this one here is x1 it goes up
to here because we want to measure the
string length ultimately and we we know
this portion here so we can subtract it
and then of course we need also x1 that
goes here x2
so now we can we can tell you up the
length let's start with this portion
here that is D minus si minus X 2 e
minus s a minus X 2 and then we have a
half circle here PI R and we know
actually that there's another half
circle gonna come there so we can just
write 2 PI R immediately and then we
have this part here that one is X 1
minus s B and then minus si minus X 2
and then finally we have this portion
and that is X 1 minus SB minus X 2
okay so the next step is that we need to
simplify this a little bit so we have 1
X 1 and another 1 here 2 X 1 plus X 2 X
2 X 2 actually 3 minus 3 X 2 and then we
have all sorts of constants we have D we
have s a as be the 2pi r but as you will
see if we differentiate this L here if
that will actually all fall away so
we're going to make a life easy and just
add a constant here and so we want to
now do the second derivative here of our
string length there is respect to time
because these are all position functions
so we can differentiate those and what's
important of course here's the string
length is not changing with time so
actually we know that a derivative will
be 0 and we can just write this up here
because x differentiate it twice is 8 so
2 a 1 minus 3 a 2 and we immediately see
from that that a 1 equals 3 a 2 so this
is our constraint condition that we will
need later for now we need to continue
with setting up Freebody diagrams of all
four objects let's start that with
object won
what's acting on object 1 well we have F
here we write it as magnitude we have F
and then we have here a tension that
goes to the pulley B that one is
different from the tension in the string
so we're going to call this TB
then we have object to oh and of course
I had goes in this direction because it
follows the motion of the object we have
here kind of the reverse now we have
attention of this string here that's
attached to pulley a but it's different
from the string tension that's a
specific one TA and we also have a T
from the string here so add T and then
if we look at pulley a we have to string
tensions T and T and here we can have a
TA and could he be TB and 2t over here
so that means we can write down our
equations of motions using Newton's
second law F equals MA and since this is
just going in the I hat direction we can
just write it down four equations
following the for Freebody diagrams here
so we have F minus TB equals m1 a1 a1 we
have
ta T plus ta equals M - a - then we have
to t minus ta equals 0 that is 0 because
we are dealing with two massless pulleys
there that means M is 0 and so our
acceleration term is 0 so the M is 0
here and finally we have TB minus 2 T
naught 2 pi 2 T and that one is also 0
because it is a massless pulley so here
we have our four equations of motion
that fully govern this this pulley
system and we can use it then for
example to find this pulling force here
we know what TB is from the equation
down here so 2 T we know what T a is
it's also 2 T and we can then solve this
for F the only sticky part is that we
have this a 1 and the a 2 in here but
for that we derived this constraint
condition so with that one we can fully
solve this otherwise we would have one
too many unknowns alternatively if one
were to be interested in one of these
accelerations then this equation system
can also be solved for a 1 or a 2